[Music]
i think the only real
way to push a eco-conscious agenda
is to just make the
things that are eco-conscious a little
more sexy
[Music]
ready freddy
my name is josh haddar i'm a metal
sculptor
my artistic platform is
sculptures
bikes
that all have the same theme of eco
consciousness and sustainability
solar energy there are lots of electric
bikes out there but you know i don't
think you're going to get a whole lot of
interest without that bike being a real
head-turner
i learned how to weld at the university
of youtube
if i didn't really have anything in mind
to build when i started a weld i just
loved the process
[Music]
this bike not only runs on solar energy
but it was completely created by solar
energy
the same
system that i used to power the
batteries i used to power all my hand
tools and basically all of these are are
made strictly by hand tools
and then basically once you buy it
there's virtually no costs you know you
don't have to gas it up you know
whatever the solar from the sky through
the sun
once i had my kids my priorities really
changed and that was just you know
i want a cleaner planet
you